expect mama to be Megan Markel to get
plenty of steps in because she is very
busy during her and Harry's R Oriole
trip down under yes and let's be honest
Nancy since you and I we're in London
and Windsor for the roadway look there
for the baby a pen yes we've been on a
Royal baby watch for a long time but we
also think Megan has been dropping some
very fashionable clues along the way the
Royal baby is believed to have been
conceived near the end of July right
around the time of this very public
display of affection
Megan hid the early stages of her
pregnancy with oversized coats and
flowing tops we've seen the Duchess
wearing slightly floaty outfits really
everything we've seen her in has been
pretty loose-fitting many royal watchers
suspected there was a baby on the way
when she seemed to be covering up
something under this flowy ruffle dress
a few weeks later was she dropping hints
with these words at the launch of her
charity cookbook working on this project
for the past nine months has been
a tremendous labor of love of course she
would have known that she was in the
early stages of pregnancy so maybe that
was just her own subtle nod to the fact
that that was in fact which child this
loose-fitting peplum top said of a new
course of baby rumors even if pregnant
Megan showed off her sporty side with a
game of netball thank you so much it's
incredibly special to be here today at
her first solo event she wore a belted
loose-fitting black dress that showed
off a slight hint of a bump and a
showing of art from Australia New
Zealand she delighted event goers by
rubbing noses a traditional New Zealand
or greeting and earlier this month on
their first visit to Sussex Megan donned
a flowy camel coat that disguised her
middle later she took it off displaying
a green leather skirt that was tight
across her tummy on that day the couple
greeted young kids and we just loved
Harry's expression when meeting this
baby all we can say is
[Music]